foreign
comes from Haley in Virginia my
boyfriend has talked about proposing
sometime in the coming months I know I
want to marry him but there is one thing
holding me back from committing
completely he has a ton of debt he's a
full-time college student at a private
university and has around thirty
thousand dollars in debt already he
doesn't have a job so he is just
continuing to accrue the debt and not
pay on it I'm a full-time college
student but I also work a full-time job
I have no doubt at all and it is very
concerning to me that I would be taking
in all of his debt if I marry him now
how do we navigate this wow well I think
very first thing is to have that
conversation because the fact that
you're thinking about marriage with this
guy and he's continuing to accrue debt
that's an issue it'd be one thing if he
like had debt and you guys are on the
same page and you're gonna tackle it
when you're married but the fact that he
has it and doesn't seem concerned about
it he doesn't really want to work to pay
it off and he's just kind of continuing
to take it on I think you guys have to
have a real level setting conversation
to go okay here's how I view money this
is my goal for the future I don't want
to have debt I'm working really hard now
while a full-time student so that I can
have you know freedom in the future and
won't be stressed by money if we're
gonna enter into this agreement together
if we're gonna be married
I don't want to live my life that way
yeah yeah the dollar amount honestly
Haley concerns me less because I
wouldn't say not to marry someone
because they have debt I mean yeah that
doesn't bother me but what value what
bothers me is the values conversation
what you're saying Christina like if he
says oh yeah I don't care
um about having debt and I'm gonna you
know have credit card debt I'll probably
take out car loans all that then your
values are off at that point and that's
the conversation you guys need to have
and get even deeper to the why you know
like why don't you want to have debt
what's your why is it because
um you know how you grew up and you're
fearful is it because you've experienced
not having margin before and it stresses
you out is it because you know you want
this feeling of security like what's
your why for living debt free and I want
to know his why if if he does I don't
want to put this on him but I'm assuming
you know he's somewhat okay with debt or
he's just as a he's a college or he's
20 years old and he's a normal college
student in the world and doesn't know
there's another way but if you you know
you guys talk about it and he still was
like no I don't care because I want to
enjoy my life and I want to whatever the
thing is that he's okay living in that
then again that's a values conversation
that you guys have to have and the truth
is is that money fights and money
problems is one of the leading causes of
divorce in America today
I had a friend in America he was like
yeah if like
the if like the number one reason people
died in your neighborhood was because of
bears people would be reading about
bears they'd be freaked out about bears
there'd be meetings about bears everyone
would be talking about bears and it's
like how do we unpoint the Bears how do
we get them away how do the strategies I
mean right people you be freaked out and
so when you hear one of the leading
causes of divorce when you're entering a
marriage you should be like okay what do
we do about this like it should be and
on fire so I feel that urgency from you
Haley which I'm so thankful to hear that
because it is a big deal but also it's
less about the dollar amounts of I mean
if I if if Winston Cruz back in the day
had two hundred thousand dollars in debt
but he said never again we're not doing
it I would still marry him and we would
have a we'd have a road to climb to get
out together as a married couple because
I'd still marry him I love him you know
uh but I think it's important like if he
says so you have this values
conversation and he says okay I'm
willing to change I I wanted I didn't
realize that taking out student loans
wasn't something I should do I want to
get on board have a great financial
future like I think after that before
you get married it's good to see
evidence of change like that it's not
just a conversation where he's like yeah
and then the next semester he takes out
another you know fifteen thousand
dollars in debt like especially at this
phase you're in where there's like a
very obvious outcome
um in terms of is he going to take on
more debt or not pay attention to that
because I mean if he really wants to
marry you and he's excited to marry you
um we don't want him to just say he's
compromising or you know say something
so that you know you get across you know
the the marriage line and then he
doesn't actually change so I think you
have an opportunity to also see you know
once you have that conversation how he
perceives yep some evidence in it yeah
but great question Haley